tu me retrouve seul dans mon lit comme
d'habitude a soudain vers 3 heures du
matin je me sens prend
[Musique]
est ce que vous avez vécu des
expériences paranormales vous savez
qu'il ya gosses de ce soir il ya mulder
et scully qui reviennent sur m6 vendredi
prochain vous bajra castaldi qu'est ce
qui s'est passé alors moi il m'est
arrivé une chose absolument incroyable
c'était en bretagne a déjà où j'étais en
bretagne j'adore la bretagne c'est
l'endroit où on est plus regarder
absolument éviter avec eux et donc ma
mère était là il y avait ma tante et il
y avait ma première femme non il y avait
combien de femmes et ma première fois
moi s'appelait aleri valérie et donc ma
mère alain guéridon qui lui vient de sa
mère et un cd et elle me dit tiens on va
faire une petite séance de spiritisme et
on commence et à la séance de spiritisme
tout se passe bien et on pose la
question
esprit es tu là et là le le guéridon se
soulève tout seul et tape un coup un
pour 8 2 pour non moi je dis ce possible
écarté vos mains que je fais je vais la
faire courte pas comme isabelle bout
d'un moment on demande à savoir avec qui
on est on est rentrés encore en
communication et en fait au large de
l'eau était à afin maloya les deux sens
là où est mort longue de ma mère non et
il a énoncé son prénom
à ce moment là on a tout sur une
trouille épouvantable le guéridon est
parti tout seul dans la pièce il a
descendu deux escaliers
le guerrier way et s'est fracassé contre
un mur là on a hurlé sa vieille bonne
assurance vie et la règle un courant
s'est coupé non ce jour là je n'ai plus
eu mais hier il est électricien votre on
partage tout à fait refermée de melvin
et j'ai eu dans ses pages c'est ouf la
tête de mes looks de tous les enfants en
quoi
valérie bénaïm un jour elle s'est jetée
rythme il ya une boulette et elle a
écrit couscous comme ça dans le ciel
c'est la vie que j'ai une vie des plus
trépidantes et les batteries et la nouba
dans le sud
dans ma famille et jusque là j'ai essayé
de me retrouver un peu au klm au calme
comme disent les jeunes
ok tu me retrouve seul dans mon lit
comme d'habitude a soudain vers 3 heures
du matin je me sens prendre
je sens qu'on me prend ça très pressenti
prendre de la soul avait sonné mais des
comme ça j'ai vu une lumière blanche et
même très très extrêmement biberon
c'était une lumière blanche et il le
mérite
écoutez c'est très écouté vous faites ce
que vous voulez dites-nous juste où vous
l'avez acheté acheté du tout il vous est
sûre c'est vraiment réel donc soulevé
lumière blanche
je vibrais et c'était tellement intense
que j'ai demandé à cette lumière blanche
de me dire oh mais moi dans mon lit
tranquillement et donc je suis revenu
dans le lit et de monsieur loyer
automatiquement j'étais transférant ce
n'est jamais autant que nationale
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la première fois c'est toujours un petit
peu de leurs bouchons
[Applaudissements]
et ni arabes ni un coq marché des
nouvelles réalités
donc j'ai pris note des prix note pour
m'en souvenir je ne me souvenais plus à
garder mes notes ça existe vraiment et
voilà donc c'était très raciste une
histoire pas piquer merci j'ai eu
plusieurs aventures curieux devançant le
sel dans un château
on avait loué un château à bordeaux ce
jeu c'était 1000 euros vraiment c'était
pas cher les châteaux à louer guti ou
tourner la loi château 1000 euros
l'heure c'est vraiment moi à 4 et donc
on avait pris chacun une aile du château
n'est pas un an on était alors étudiant
à l'époque on avait moi château quand
même des chapeaux auvergne et des idées
c'est le second cas il n'a pas dans
léolo de se dire je vais leur camping
genou alors que chacun dans une halle du
château c'était génial d'aller vraiment
au pion c'était et c'est bon c'est
terrible et donc un soir quelqu'un
rentre dans la chance je pensais que
c'était un de mes amis peut-être qu'ils
avaient un problème je voulais me parlez
pas du tout je vois cette personne aller
vers la fenêtre elle se dresse devant la
fenêtre vous avez fait des gestes comme
ça et c'est à ces personnes errantes à
travers la fenêtre c'est julien courbet
[Rires]
elle est venue régulièrement et c'est
curieux j'ai pas vraiment eu peur je lui
parle évidemment je répondais pas mal
avec arsène m'a regardé mais je vais
vous dire le plus marrant évidemment
quand j'ai raconté au post le lendemain
matin a bien sûr ah ouais si ça madame
irma n'importe quoi alors trop tard et
était bourré match et c'est très bien
sauf qu'un jour on reçoit la
propriétaire du château mais vraiment
six mois après je les voyais souvent de
ce monsieur et elle nous dit oui vous
savez en bernard vous êtes ou dans le
château où je dis je suis allé là bas
qui donne sur le lac à 1000 sympa
c'était le bureau de mon fils non me
direz mais monfils le pauvre il est mort
ne savait pas de la vie de cette dame
avait loué le château était adorable et
dans l'escalier elle nous sort une photo
elle sort une photo et moi j'avais
décrit non et décrit le mec avec mes
potes mais c'est un oui je sais c'est
impressionnant ça j'ai plein d'autres
histoires mais ce serait bien c'est bon
tu envoies ce tout le monde l'avait déjà
l'histoire est bien il ya quatre ans
donc à trois zones et maintenant je me
fais remercier d'nrj12 l'aj auxerre j'en
ai fait les frais quand il coupe tout
peut arriver et d'un changement de
direction j'ai ressenti ça sent et se
disaient pas très bien et du coup j'en
discute avec des élus qui ni pourquoi
pas voir une voyante jamais un seul n'a
vu super cartésienne absents j'y vais
dans 14e et je vois une voyante qui me
fait trois prédiction c'est vrai et la
première et me dit très rapidement je
vois entourée d'animaux dont j'aime
beaucoup les animaux et là vous avez
fait et la vie de ta mère je te promets
que c'est vrai deux mois après le patron
d'nrj jusque dans que nouveau stefano
m'appelle et me dit tu vas faire ou non
l'un des animaux et tout ça est là elle
va des bonnes prédictions on aère
incroyable clairvoyante
il ya même deuxième est là elle n'avait
pas donné l'eau douce
[Applaudissements]
deuxième prédictions ne me dit très
rapidement ensuite vous allez rencontrer
votre idole alors comme le télé le
téléphone a sonné que vous m'avez appelé
la pmp je me suis dit mais c'était vous
est pas complètement voit cette époque
là on se connaissait pas bien il n'y
avait pas de sens si tu comprenais pas
vous votre idole mon idole et l'époque
je leur ai dit que des conneries jure
que c'est vrai je reçois un coup de
téléphone du producteur était invité à
bercy à au concert de justin bieber nom
est tu pourra le rencontrer je suis un
des seuls je suis un des seuls giuly
zarma chez un des seuls barbare quand
j'arrive au concert à bercy on me dit
l'a pas encore joué tu peux dans sa loge
je me suis déjà vu mais repris sa carte
bleue oui mais oui mais oui mais oui tu
va casser tout mais alors et donc moi je
vais le voir anna je les veux juste
quelques minutes dans sa loge après la
3e prédiction c'est quoi la troisième a
fait une prédiction pour 2018 vous allez
rester beaucoup chez vous bien un
troisième set et bref c'était que dans
les cinq ans donc c'est à trois ans et
demi cette histoire là c'était vrai on
est cinq ans je ferai du cinéma non y
arrive taxi 5
c'est fou c'est pas fou non mais vous
venez au chaud alors je pas t'en dire
plus parce que même toi tu seras surpris
mais arrive taxi 5
et même s'il garde temps mais je peux le
dire maintenant parce qu'il n'est pas là
je me préfère ça la rend les gens quand
ils sont pourtant bien que debbie
bloquer un petit peu c'est pas besson
qui bloquait donc vous avez joué dans
des taxis 5
on saura ça mardi voilà
[Musique]